[Music]
hi
i'm john helveston and thanks for tuning
in my lightning talk on how to make
r-powered surveys with former
if you're someone who has ever had to
make a survey chances are you've
probably used something like
surveymonkey or google forms
and these platforms work great for
simple surveys
but what if you needed to make something
that was a little more complex than what
these platforms offer
well thankfully some really clever
people made former which uses
r and r markdown code to create rich
complex surveys
now just to be clear i'm not one of
those clever people former was actually
developed by
reuben arsene and cyril tata i'm just a
former super fan
and i made this talk to share it with
the rest of the art community
and to demonstrate some of the cool
things that you can do with it
so what can former do well i kind of
think of it
like survey monkey plus our markdown you
can use it to create simple surveys
but you can also use our code to
generate a much richer
set of features for example you could
create
interactive charts that survey
respondents could then experience
while taking the survey or
you could use our code to generate
dynamic feedback
for example images like this were
generated with ggplot code
for each respondent in a longitudinal
study showing them
their risk preferences for different
activities based on their answers to
previous questions
so at this point you might be wondering
how all this works so let's dig into
some of the details
surveys and former are built using open
source components
the text and code for each survey are
input using google sheets
and once the survey is live our code is
computed using open cpu
this makes it really easy to make your
work as transparent as you'd like
so here's an example google sheet each
row is an item that will be displayed on
the survey
and each column controls what will be
shown
the label column is where you insert
markdown or code chunks
that you want to display in the survey
the type column is where you set the
type of each question to show
you can choose from a long list of
options like multiple choice questions
text entry or simply just display some
text or images
depending on the type of question you
may also have some options for
respondents that you want them to choose
from
like in a multiple choice question and
you can also customize the look and feel
with some styling options
it's kind of analogous to an r markdown
document where the style and question
type columns are sort of like the yaml
and the label and choice columns contain
the content that you want to display
once you've got your spreadsheet ready
you can then log into former.org
input the link to your google sheet and
former will convert it into a survey
the example i just showed generates a
survey with some multiple choice
questions about apples that look like
this
in a web browser once your survey is
live
you can then use the associated former
package to go
import results in a nicely formatted
data frame directly into r
now that we know a little bit about how
former works i'd like to show a couple
examples of how i've used it
in my own work and i'll start with an
example of showing people randomized
images
in a research method known as conjoint
analysis
in conjoint surveys you ask people to
choose from randomized profiles of
different products
you can then use that choice data to
estimate their preferences
for attributes of those products so for
example if i wanted to know how people
felt about the price or freshness of
different apples
i could ask them to choose from profiles
like this and then in each choice
question
i'll randomly vary the values that i'm
showing them
because i'm working in r i can
pre-define all those profiles
in a data frame so in this example the
three profiles shown
are generated from the first three rows
of this data frame
i've also used former to create timed
randomized quizzes for my class
i do this by creating a a and b version
of every question on a quiz then i use
the sample function to randomly select a
version for each question
in this example you might be asked
what's your favorite animal
or what your favorite color depending on
which question is selected
with just a five question quiz i can
generate 32
unique combinations of quizzes and in
this particular example i've also added
a timer so that
the quiz will automatically submit when
the time is up
so that's just a few examples of how
i've used former but i encourage you to
check out former.org to see some of the
other complex designs that you might
want to make
like longitudinal or diary studies with
automated email and text messaging
reminders
today over a million people have filled
out a survey on former
and there's a growing user base with a
very active support group
so you'll have all the help you need to
build whatever survey you want
so head on over to former.org and start
making some r-powered surveys
you